I guess it's Jonah here so for today's
workout we want to focus on tuning of
the back muscles and also getting rid of
bags back we all know that we cannot
spot reduced fat okay so this workout
will also work on your total body it's
going to combine a 45 seconds of back
exercises with 45 seconds of active rest
so you will constantly be moving
throughout the entire workout so get a
body warmed up and let's do this workout
together so for this workout you will
need two pairs of dumbbells one heavier
weight I would say between 6 to 8 kilos
each and one lighter weight just between
2 to 3 kilos each if you don't have a
pair of dumbbells you can always make
your own at home ok so the first workout
will be sent over row so let's start
with the pair of heavier dumbbell okay
so stand sugar with the pot and I want
you to pull and squeeze it back muscles
bring your elbows up squeeze to with
your belly and just hold it one count
lower it down up and down ok so avoid
punching or collapsing your chat always
keep a back slide open and squeeze your
back muscles good so we want to be doing
this for 45 seconds do not rush the
workout really fill every muscle being
engaged good squeeze
holy squeeze the back muscles bring your
elbows back nice keep going
few more release low keep the weight
close to your side please and just drop
it
let's get straight into jumping jacks so
this is your 45 seconds of active rest
ok so we were constantly moving
throughout the entire workout yes and
this is when you can sort of like slow
down catch your breath just breathe a
little bit
remember breathe in without and pizza
Brittany second workout will be plank
row so still on the heavier weight keep
going 15 more seconds of active rest and
then back to strength
ready to work on your mid-back five more
seconds
good now let's get down onto the mat all
right into a plank position all I'm
going to do is pull the right on up
screechy back muscles and then alternate
with your left okay this is a more
advanced version if you find this to be
challenging what you can do is drop onto
your knees pull and squeeze good so your
body should always maintain flat on the
throw
keep going and as you progress lift and
pull and squeeze so do not over arch or
do not stick your butt in the air
keep your body flat pull and squeeze
your back muscles so this workout also
really work on your core strength good
bring your elbows back squeeze nice and
now drop the waist second set of active
rest shuffle to your side sir shuffle
touchdown shuffle and touch so ladies
remember we cannot spot reduced-fat
all this workout will work on a total
body at the same time it's great to tone
your entire body up especially your back
muscles keep going good the third
workout
let's lift light up it will be focusing
on the upper back reverse lie
ten more seconds stay low and tap down
keep going say hello tap down and let's
grab the lights of hair and stand bend
from your weight open and squeeze your
upper back bring it back down low open
and squeeze good so the focus is to
really focus on your upper back bring it
front open and squeeze very nice
keep going squeeze hold for two counts
right at the top squeeze engage bring it
back down squeeze and back down good so
remember do not rush the
one okay control engaged and feel your
muscles working good one more give me
one more and it's back to active rest so
put the dumbbells down and let's just
bring on the spot okay to run as far as
you can work on your legs we're going to
hydrate bring your heart rate up all
right small but fast movement here keep
going
breathe in and breathe out pace your
breathing listen your heart rate well I
can feel my heart rate pumping I can
feel my sweat dripping and my favorite
word's ah sweat if you're fat crying
keep going keep running last 20 seconds
bring the spit up and one final workout
which will be on the floor right let's
get on to the floor live the life of
hair I want it to work on Superman I'm
back screen so bring the weights up and
squeeze your back back down good up
squeeze release down good so this will
work on the upper back your mid-back
handle to your lower back down
up squeeze and down
very nice last one roll up on a few more
and down up squeeze expand and down good
if you find it to be challenging release
the weight and just do it without any
weight as you progress then lift some
weight
okay three more keep going and the final
workout halo let's work on mountain
climbers the last 45 seconds keep your
heart racing and we will get a
one-minute break good bring your knees
in keep your back flat arms in line with
the shoulders see your sweat is dripping
on the floor keep racing
not stop now one last active rep and you
will get a one-minute break woof
breathe in and out
keep going ladies stay strong stay with
me keep racing and well done that was
your first set now I want you to grab
some water keep yourself hydrated
inhale exhale bring your heart rate down
and we want to do the second stat all
right so get some water and keep it up a
traitor
[Music]
so this is your second set you know all
the move okay so I want you to move from
one workout to the next workout
efficiently as possible okay let's not
waste time
so the first workout will be sent over
rows to grab your heavier pair of
dumbbells let's get into position
remember to always value from your waist
keep your back straight chest up keep
your knees up and let's go root with
your belly release squeeze your back
muscles is all about engaging the right
muscles you should feel your mid-back
working good keep pulling keep the waist
close to your thighs okay nice squeeze
and release breathe in and breathe out
as you put it back up okay without
breathe in and breathe out
good pace your breathing the better you
pace your breathing the better you will
be at your workout nice keep going whoo
squeeze right at the top bring your
elbows back look gently at the floor few
more and straight into jumping jacks
weight down let's go
jumping jacks good okay push it really
push it take this moment to really bring
your heart rate up and work on your
cardio nice total body workout it's
always the best way to burn fat and also
to do these muscle good
keep jumping halfway there and we want
to get straight into plank row whew type
in your course where you're up and down
nice and more [ __ ] your heart rate
pumping and now let's get down onto the
floor bring the waist close to your body
into a plank position pull and squeeze
your back keeping your body as straight
as possible again remember beginners you
can always start on your knees
good you can step slightly wider to find
your balance squeeze this is not an easy
workout but it's really effective on
your core and also your back muscle this
is one of my favorite workouts I will
always do it every week in fact in every
workout session that I do keep going
put Twitter belly click it back we leave
gently and drop few more and it straight
into your active rep one more and drop
it
let's go side to side shuffle ok
touchdown stay low and touchdown good
shuffle will make muscles working and
just gently tap jump get into deep squat
and tap whew and the next workout grab
your lighter pair of them down tap and
breathe good
keep those legs muscles strong and feel
but working at the same time good tap
keep moving
last one and now grab you like to type
down bell and let's get it to reverse
fly so same thing then bring your weight
open and squeeze your other back and
open your shoulders squeeze release
gently in front of you squeeze and
release all right remember do not ever
hunch or collapse your back okay this is
wrong
open chest up back black squeeze engage
side your core squeeze and engage good
up hold release low up and release good
because the upper back and your shoulder
muscles are small muscles so you will
need only a lighter pair of dumbbells
few more one more
and release
in position let's sprint as fast as we
can okay so more movement again back
flat on both side work on those legs and
sprint as fast as we can
good whew now this is a time to really
listen to your heart rate keep pushing
it
yes I know it's not a date you want to
catch your breath but she's going only
15 seconds left let's go
tip your calf muscles strong ten more
seconds keep going ladies and we want to
get straight into Superman down onto the
floor okay you can either choose to grab
you like to grab dumbbells I'll do it
without any wings and click go up and
squeeze
Oh down up and squeeze release and down
up mix up sweet release and down good up
we release and down again option up
three release and slowly down here
you'll know Mac as you come up
so really bring the legs up your body up
look straight ahead and squeeze your low
back muscles keep going and really if
you want to grab your weight squeeze up
and release good one final workout my
mat is built with my sweat let's go
mountain climber the bring your knees to
watch each hand and imagine you're
climbing up the hill
keep going alright elbows shoulders in
line with your hands okay keep climbing
I can just see start dripping like it's
ready keep going well one left workout
and you're done
right ten more seconds let's bring it up
let's not stop now bring this bit up
do not stop now okay keep going
three two one ah I just take them over
to breathe and rest around
I hope you enjoyed this workout and I
hope you're drenched in sweat it's just
like me remember that the most efficient
way to build lean muscles and also to
burn fat is to combine both strength
training and also cardio exercises this
workout it's really shot but it is
really efficient because you're doing
the entire sequence non-stop so for best
results do this workout three times
weekly on alternate days and you can
combine this workout with my other
workout videos which you can check it
out right here ok so if you enjoyed this
video be sure to share with your friends
get your friends to do this workout like
this video and subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more workout videos
and other healthy recipes all the best